good evening ladies and gentlemen and of
course all other configurations of beam
my name is wilbur warfare boy did you
have a good Jesus
anyway like I was saying we have a great
guest for you tonight some people call
him the king of the squirrels some
people call him the king of five nights
at freddys most people just call him
daddy please welcome mr. markiplier
welcome sir thanks for having me our
producer couldn't find any other way to
boost our ratings so you play video
games for a living yeah yeah video games
my life I do it all day it's my job I
love it now what exactly is it that you
do while playing these treacherous
virtual brain dumpsters yeah yeah well
basically I play games record it
commentate over it and upload it to
youtube it's called the let's play show
are you commentate yeah yeah so what is
it exactly that you markiplier
commentate video games I play them and
then I film my reaction to them what
reaction go water I know let's get down
to the nitty brake yes yeah
now what games would you say have been
the biggest draw of your channel yeah
yeah in the beginning I first started
playing amnesia the Dark Descent moved
on to the Slenderman games very popular
and more recently five nights at
Freddy's became yeah yeah
yeah yeah five nine siffredi who's a
really big thing people love that one
and I don't know if so which one of
these games would you say is your
favorite oh yeah I get asked this
question all the time people want to
know what my favorite game is boy you
got a lot of fans
yeah yeah I almost have 10 million
subscribers yeah yeah I have no idea
happened I when I started out I had
nothing I literally took my tax refund
thank you and I bought computer
equipment recording equipment everything
I need to just get started and I started
with absolutely nothing no one watched
my videos and then over time it just
grew into something big bigger than I
ever thought possible anyway have you
ever met one of these yeah I I meet fans
all the time I go to conventions all
around and murder their entire family no
no no I have not no no so you admit it
you heard it here first ladies ellezi
markiplier has Justin made you never
murdering anyone no I didn't say that
honey can we can we get back to the
questions please found wife someone yeah
this shows getting ridiculous these
questions don't even matter
the audience is drunk or high or
something and you're an idiot like why
would anyone listen to you ever
no no no no no your star no like it no
stop
what do we learn all right well then
we're back to the interval oh if I may
call me I'm gonna swim yes so I heard
you've done a great deal of charity work
okay looks like someone doesn't want to
cooperate with interview anymore well
thank you markiplier for joining us
sorry for disappointing all of your fans
out here but once again use a great
generous handsome man you are so thank
you and thank you all out there every
configuration of being poor watching my
Nana